S
AND EVERYONE ELSE THE
BACKGROUND ON THE SKI RECALLED
THREE. NOW BUT IT SHOULDN'T BE
A SURPRISE THE NEW ABC POLL
JUST CAME OUT THIS MORNING
THREE OUT OF FOUR AMERICANS
DOUBT THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP. SO
THE THREAT OF COVID NINETEEN
SERIOUSLY ENOUGH. TO HIMSELF
AND TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SELF.
AND WHY MIKE THEY THINK THAT
WILL LOOK AT THIS SUPER
SPREADER FATMA. THIS IS AMY
CONEY BARRETT'S CEREMONY AT THE
WHITE HOUSE LOADS OF PEOPLE
SITTING VERY CLOSELY TOGETHER
FOR LONG PERIODS OF TIME WITH
NO MASKS MOST. OF THEM IN FACT.
WHEN THEY WENT IN. THEY WERE
ENCOURAGED TAKE OFF THEIR MASKS
EVEN THOUGH BEING INSIDE IS
MORE DAMAGING THAN BEING
OUTSIDE. SO WE'RE HERE TODAY
JUDGE JACARE TALK ABOUT TO
PEOPLE WHO HAVE TO TAKE ALL THE
SERIOUSLY MORE SERIOUSLY AND
ACT ON IT. THE FIRST IS MITCH
MCCONNELL. MITCH MCCONNELL
SEEMS TO BE JAMMING THROUGH THE
HEARINGS ON AMY CONEY BARRETT
EVEN THOUGH. THREE SENATORS
HAVE CALLED IT. EVEN THOUGH HE
IS SAYING IT'S NOT SAFE FOR THE
SENATE TO MEETING SESSION BUT
IT'S OKAY TO HAVE THE HEARINGS
IT MAKES NO SENSE IF IT'S NOT
SAFE FOR THE SENATE TO MEETING
SESSION. IT'S NOT SAFE TO BE
HEARINGS TO GO FOR. AND THE
IDEA OF HAVING VIRTUAL HEARINGS
WHEN NO ONE IS WITH THE WITNESS.
THE HIGHEST COURT IN THE LAND
FOR A LIFE APPOINTMENT THAT
WOULD HAVE SUCH EFFECTS. ON
PEOPLE'S LIVES MAKES NO SENSE
OF VIRTUAL HEARING. IS
VIRTUALLY NO HEARING AT ALL.
YOU NEED TO BE WITH THE WITNESS
AND HAVE DIRECT FOR. BECAUSE
QUESTIONS AND BACK AND FORTH
WITH THEM. AND WE ALL KNOW THE
NOMINATED SUPREME COURT
NOMINATION. AFFECTS PEOPLE'S
HEALTH CARE AND THEIR
PROTECTION WITH PRE EXISTING
CONDITIONS HEALTH YEAH ERIC
STANDS FOR PRESERVING OR
ELIMINATING A WOMAN'S RIGHT TO
CHOOSE. STANDS FOR KEEPING
WORKER RIGHTS STRONG VOTER
RIGHTS STRONG LBGTQ RIGHTS
STRONG. SO FOR MITCH MCCONNELL
TO GO AHEAD WITH THE HEARING.
ENDANGERS THE SAFETY NOT ONLY
OF SENATORS BUT STAFF WHO
WORKED DILIGENTLY ON THE HILL.
AND THEY OUGHT TO BE DELAYED
THERE IS NO REASON ON GOD'S
GREEN EARTH LIKE YOU SHOULDN'T
BE DELAYED OTHER THAN AN EFFORT
TO RUSSIA WITNESSED THROUGH.
INADEQUATE HEARING WHERE PEOPLE
CAN'T EVEN SEE THE WITNESS FACE
TO FACE. SO WE ARE DEMANDING
TODAY ALONG WITH MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS AND. MANY MANY GROUPS
BACKED THE HEARING PEOPLE'S. IF
MCCONNELL THAT HE BE POST IN
THE- THEY SHOULD BE POSTPONED.
AT THE HEARING LEVEL. THE
SECOND POINT IS THE PRESS. WE
NEED FOR TRANSPARENCY WE ALL
KNOW THE PRESIDENT'S CAVALIER
ATTITUDE TOWARDS COVID TOWARDS
MASS TOWARDS SOCIAL DISTANCING.
AS IN DANGER OF MANY PEOPLE
INCLUDING HIMSELF AS AGAIN THIS
PICTURE SHOWS BUT IT HAPPENED
OVER AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
SO NOW AT THE VERY MINIMUM WE
NEED FULL TRANSPARENCY. WE NEED
TO KNOW EXACTLY THE LEVEL OF
THE PRESIDENT'S SELF WE HAVE TO
KNOW WHO ELSE GOT PROBED THE-
HOW SEVERELY THEY HAPPEN. THAT
APPLIES TO THE SENATORS THAT
APPLIES TO THE WORKERS IN THE
WHITE HOUSE AND ALL THE TOP
LEVEL PEOPLE AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
WHEN YOU DON'T HAVE FULL
TRANSPARENCY. WHEN THERE'S
COVERUPS CONTRADICTORY
STATEMENTS EVEN LIE. ABOUT
SOMETHING AS VITAL TO THE
NATION'S SECURITY IS THE
PRESIDENT'S HEALTH. THE NATION
IS SEVERELY ENDANGER. WE KNOW
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS A
PENCHANT FOR NOT TELLING THE
TRUTH. WHEN IT COMES TO
SOMETHING AS VITAL AS THIS. THE
HEALTH OF THE PRESIDENT. THE
HEALTH OF THE PEOPLE AROUND HIM
WE NEED TO TELL THE WHOLE TRUTH
AND NOTHING BUT THE TRUTH. FOR
AS JOE FRIDAY SAID JUST THE
FACTS JUST THE FACTS MA'AM NO
COVER UP NO SPINNING. NO AFTER
THROUGH THE WHOLE STORE. ALL IN
ALL THE PRESS THIS BEING
TRUTHFUL FOLEY HAD ONLY WEEKS
OLD ABOUT HIS CONDITION. AND
THE CONDITION OF ALL OF THE
ROUNDS OF. LET ME ANYTHING OUT
INITIAL. NO OKAY LOWS IN THE
JEWISH. QUESTIONS ON THESE TWO
SUBJECTS WHAT WOULD HAPPEN
HAPPEN. DIDN'T HAVE FOR
KNOWLEDGE OF AND REPUBLICANS.
WELL THEY STILL AHEAD THE HERE
WITH THE CENTER NEEDS NOT
HEARING ACCORDING TO OF SENATE
THE CAN APPROACH WHEN THE SAME
IS OUT SESSION WE WILL HAVE
MANY MORE PROCEDURE OPTIONS
WHEN IT COMES TO A VOTE IN THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON A VOTE ON
THE FLOOR AND WE WILL USE EVERY
TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX. TO DELAY
AND NOT HAVE. THE VOTES THE
CARD. WELL WITH TALK ABOUT ALL
BUT WE'RE TO USE EVERY FOR.
TOOL THAT WE CAN. FIRST JOB THE
LADIES. WE CAN'T. THE DELAY.
BUT THE PUBLIC. ON THE SENATE
IS BOLTON HAVE CALLED IN AND-
WE SHOULD BE. THE SEARING WE
CAN HAVE A FULL AND FAIR VIEW.
NOT SOMETHING OVER SOON. THAT
MEASURE UP. WHEN YOU HAVE THE
MOST AVOID THAT THE SENATE
MAKES FOR LIFE. UHHUH. OKAY I
SO I HAVE THAT LOOK ON WITH
THAT ALSO GET TO AND ALL HOURS
YEAH THAT'S THE AND SO FAR HE
NOT GONE A LONG THAT NIGHT HE
IS VERY MORE. THANK YOU I. HAVE
A GOOD DAY. YEAH YOUR DOG SEVEN
MASS. YEAH IS THAT YOUR DOG MAY
HAVE FIRST AND LAST YOUR WHOLE.
TWO HOURS AGO OKAY OKAY THANK
YOU EVERYBODY. AT EXCEP